Ce que tu fais
Ce que tu dis
A beaucoup à voir avec comment tu vis aujourd'hui
Ce que tu veux
Ce que tu fais
Tout le monde sait que c'est juste ce que tu prends
Ce que tu vois
Ce que tu entends
Quand ça revient, ne semble pas clair
Tu dis "oui", ils disent "non"
Tout le monde parle partout où tu vas
Tu essaies de donner à un autre une main serviable
Et il prendra ta gentillesse pour de la faiblesse
Ne jamais faire aux autres ce qu'il te font
Essaie de trouver une autre façon d'y arriver
Ce que je dis
Est ce que je sais
Essaie d'obtenir des faveurs en allant de porte en porte
Tu t'arrêtes et pries
C'est démodé
Tu fais un pas, ça demande une centaine de miles
Ce que je dis est ce que je sais
Essaie d'obtenir des faveurs en allant de porte en porte
Tu t'arrêtes et pries, c'est démodé
Tu fais un pas, ça demande une centaine de miles
Tu essaies de donner à un autre une main serviable
Et il prendra ta gentillesse pour une faiblesse
Ne jamais faire aux autres ce qu'ils te font
Tu as intérêt à leur faire avant qu'ils te le fassent
Ce que tu fais
Et ce que tu dis
A beaucoup à voir avec comme tu vis aujourd'hui
Ce que tu veux
Ce que tu fais
Tout le monde sait que ce n'est que ce que tu prends
Ce que tu vois
Ce que tu entends
Quand ça te revient, ce n'est pas la même chose
Parce que tu vas dire "oui", et ils vont dire "non"
Et tout le monde commencera à parler, parler, et blabla, partout où tu vas
Et tu sais quoi ?Tu essaies de donner à un autre homme une main serviable
Et tu sais ce qu'il fera ? Il prendra ta gentillesse pour une faiblesse
Tu essaies de faire aux autres ce que tu aimerais qu'ils te fassent
Mais comprends-le, ça sera un tout autre genre de choses
Alors tu essaies de donner une main serviable à un autre homme
Et il prendra ta gentillesse pour une faiblesse
Ne jamais faire aux autres ce qu'ils te font